keine andere schweizer stadt hat eine
vergleichbare dichte an luxusmarken wie
genf das lockt jährlich 90.000
chinesische touristen an wie dieses
wohlhabende ehepaar aus einer
millionenmetropole hongkong
sie sind auf uhren jagd genever
touristen bietet solche shopping touren
an
in den letzten zehn jahren sind in china
1,8 millionen neue millionäre entstanden
rund 20 neue milliarde
das heißt 500 neue millionäre pro tag
können sich das vorstellen
diese viele neureichen möchten luxus
güter kaufen und die schweizer uhr steht
dabei ganz oben auf ihrer liste
zuerst etwas sightseeing und dann
einzutauchen in die luxusmeile riedel
grone um etwas passendes fürs handgelenk
zu finden
erster halt die luxusmarke jimmy
wer sich alles leisten kann der möchte
das besitzen was nur wenige haben können
das gehört zum selbstverständnis der
neuen oberschicht in china das wissen
auch die uhren verkäuferinnen am lac
léman exklusivität ist alles das schlägt
sich auf dem kreis nieder
wie hoch ist der preis
wir haben bei diesem exklusiven zeit
stück einen preis von 220 tausend
schweizer franken
es gehört zu einer limitierten auflage
doch dem prüfenden blick der gattin hält
die limitierte auflage dann doch nicht
stand marco rodriguez ist videoproduzent
und uhren experte und produziert für den
youtube kanal der watch ist i
für ihn ist klar die schweizer uhr ist
für die chinesen ein statussymbol über
das sie mehr wissen wollen
wenn china reicht es nicht mehr aus mit
einer teuren schweizer wo am handgelenk
zu prahlen
die chinesischen kunden wollen heute
mehr wissen sie möchten verstehen was
die schweizer uhren macherey so
besonders macht dabei sein wenn eine uhr
entsteht durch organisiert für uhren
fans aus china ausflüge zu den
traditionellen uhren machern im vallée
de joux in der westschweiz
einmal dem künstler zuschauen können
dessen oder man trägt dieses bedürfnis
wird bei den chinesen bereits in der
heimat kultiviert die uhrenmacher werden
als das an fehlenden promo partys in
hongkong und singapur präsentiert die
schweizer uhr soll exklusives
lebensgefühl vermitteln
richtig lokale filmstars als
markenbotschafter diese idole machen den
mythos und den helvetischen zeitmesser
perfekt auch deshalb ist die schweizer
uhr in china ein beliebtes schmiermittel
seit dem neuen anti korruptionsgesetz
unterschieden ping geht das aber nicht
mehr so einfach
früher kam es nicht selten vor dass die
chinesin nach genf 23 patrick figuren
kaufte auf einen schlag oder 20 rolex
uhr
denn mit einer schweizer uhr konnte man
sich in china sehr gut in die gunst von
jemanden klingen da die politik seit
einigen jahren aber härter durchgreift
müssen die chinesen vielmehr aufpassen
in die gunst der partnerin können sich
mit einer schweizer uhr aber sehr wohl
noch bringen das ist in genf bekannt und
charmiert was das zeug hält
mit dieser uhr können sie beide sehr gut
miteinander unterwegs sein
sie kostet 20 1400 franken bei
schnäppchen kommt man doch mit dem
besitz einer schweizer uhr einer
chinesischen kaiser hin er die
chinesischen herrscher familien liebten
schweizer uhren
einige dieser stücke sind heute im patek
philippe sehen in genf ausgestellt
die chinesischen touristen möchten hier
also sehen welche uhren ihre kaiserinnen
und kaiser damals getragen haben
interessant ist auch dass es in den 1970
er jahren mode war das der bräutigam der
braut als geschenk eine schweizer uhr
kaufte das paar in genf möchte ein
anderes mal wieder kommen ohne kameras
der besuch hat sich trotzdem gelohnt
ich habe wieder mehr gelernt über das
uhren handwerk ich bewundere wirklich
die meisterleistung und die hohe
expertise die ihnen zu einer
handgemachten schweizer uhr steckt von
dieser präzision kann man auch für sein
eigenes leben lernen
die original schweizer uhr überzeugt
auch wenn sich die chinesen im eigenen
land von jeder luxusuhr eine kopie
kaufen könnten
die chinesen sind keine meiste der
uhrenmacher aber sie sind meist den
business so einfach ist das mit anderen
worten wir haben die zeit die chinesen
das geld am ende ist halt alles käuflich
auch eine jahrhunderte alt